now that a high rate but almost 13 per
game but they can't afford to use those
possessions because they don't shoot it
that well that's Nikhil [ __ ] under 10
you got to find a way to penetrate yeah
and I just think the Hokies are doing
such a fantastic job they're not giving
up any penetration because of the lack
of height no post play by st. Louis
these pins trying to keep those limbs
warm now let's see the Walker sticking
with it log they just lose his talent he
hates in a freshman at a Charlotte North
Carolina and he's checked into the game
first time we've seen each other through
st. Louis what a finish alexander walker
actually started conference play with
five straight wins when it went through
so much so we finished alexander Walker
you know one thing st. Louis cannot look
at the scoreboard did you see that boom
unbelievable and Alexander Walker
starting to sprinkle his Stardust on
this game this is huge
never touches his right hand that is
skill using that six a crane Goodwin has
his pocket picks Alexander Walker
the field is he'll to take their time we
run this clock down run some sets blacks
here again that passing ability out of
the high post to locate Alexander Walker
and you see the cutters coming off of
him as I said no rush
more game-high 20 points in the win over
st. Louis who sit you up with 20 or more
in three of his last four here he comes
again
knifing through the defense as soon as
this piece paper so far good start for
Liberty with the two-point lead I think
this is Liberty's kind of game they've
just got to avoid the mistakes baseball
pass and done that in the last three or
four possessions
Elijah coffee on a three flames starting
to settle for some threes here let's
hear a little bit of contact no whistle
make it eight straight points mixed ties
eight lead changes we're just under
seven minutes gone by
what a pass inside blacks here why don't
we to find a way to see if he gets cata
down on the block yeah it's better now
I'm nervous to study games in my opinion
Cabell lost a handle here on Friday
night Acer champions kick-out pass into
the hands of Alexander Walker Hill left
open pump fakes
Friday night a certain champions kick
out pass into the hands of Alexander
Walker and left open pump banks
[Applause]
exploring the defense when they had
success in the first half they were
flushing the defense to play Alexander
precious seconds coming off the clock
Blackshear so good in the high post
Alexander backs here what court vision
by the south mark as it was there in the
first half and I'm finishing the things
at the rim neither loves left he loves
laugh blow by Canada the night without
cam reddish this is one you need Walker
to step up
[Applause]
his kid really is talented big quiet
[Applause]
and it ends up in the hands of
Blackshear go the black shirt
oh what a shot and ran Xavier Walker
always got to go up the dump back today
Jones a black Cher offensive rebound
nice drivin and he'll the baseline
roaming free the first field goal